Yeah, why don't I start today?
I just want to acknowledge the injury with Tyler Roberts.
It was a kind of a freak accident on the pitch...
...and we knew it was going to be a pretty heavy injury right away,...
...but Tyler was adamant about wanting to stay on the pitch for the rest of the match,...
...which I appreciated...
...and it helped us a little bit maybe in set piece situations and whatnot.
But he had a successful surgery,...
...which we texted a little bit after the surgery and he was in positive spirits...
...and the surgeon feels like it went well,...
...so we're hopeful that he'll have a full recovery...
...and in three to four months time be strong and ready and back at 100%
Jesse, can you just sort of sum up how your time has been here so far...
...with ten days, first game under your belt?
How's the settling in period?
Yeah, you know the nice thing is, it's slowing down a little bit.
The first days when you come, there's a million things on your mind...
...and a million things to take care of and you gotta get to know people more and more.
Now we've spent more intensive time with each other,...
...everything from the people here at the training center to the staff at the stadium...
...to obviously the players and I think that we've enjoyed our time together.
It's been very positive.
We obviously felt good about the first performance...
...despite not getting the result that we thought we wanted and frankly deserved,...
...but we know that those good feelings will stay strong when we can get the results.
So the focus and concentration to try to push every day...
...to understand exactly what direction we want to go and it has been good...
...and we will need that in this coming week.